GERMAN WE WELCOME YOU TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WERE GONNA BE CALLING
THE MEETING TO ORDER WE WELCOME
YOU TO OUR FIRST ASSEMBLY BILL
HEARING FACING GENTLEMAN OF
CANADIAN TO THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING ONLINE IN HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS WE HAVE A TWELVE TOTAL
BILLS THAT ARE GOING TO BE IN
FRONT OF US TODAY ELEVEN WILL
BE ON KANSEN WE WILL BE HAVING
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB'S TWO SEVENTY ONE
SOME NUMBER OF OUR BAR RIVAS IN
JUST A FEW MOMENTS. TODAY HE
WILL BE ASKING ONCE WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM FOR MOTION
ON ITEMS TWO THROUGH TWELVE
WHICH WILL BE OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR TWO DAYS BEFORE WE GET
STARTED THOUGH LET'S ESTABLISH
THAT QUORUM THEN WILL ASK FOR A
MOTION ON OUR CONSENT CALENDAR
MR CANAL GOOD MORNING IF YOU
CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR MCGUIRE HERE REQUIRE
PRESIDENT SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN PRESIDENT SENATOR DRAWS
DORADO PRESENT. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SO WIENER. WE
PRESIDENT YOU HAVE A QUORUM
COMES IN SABAH FOR HIM ARE
PRESS- WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO
SEE IF THERE IS A MOTION ON OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MR CANAL CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MOTION
IS TO ADOPT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SENATOR MCGUIRE HI
MCGUIRE- A SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI SENATOR DORADO
DURAZO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WINNER WIENER HI
HITTING COUNTERS CURRENTLY FOUR
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
CAN CONTAIN COUNTER ON CALL TO
ALLOW THE MAJORITY LEADER TO BE
OUT ADELINE ST IN GENERAL WE DO
WANNA WELCOME ITSELF VARGAS-
MISS FARGAS IS THE NEW KIND OF
NOT REALLY COMMITTEE ASSISTANT-
MISS FARGAS SAID STARTED HERE
DURING THE PANDEMIC THIS IS HER
FIRST MEETING IN PERSON AND I
MISS VARGAS STAND FOR A MOMENT
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO WELCOME
HER. TO COMMITTEE AND AT FIRST
PERSONALITY PURPOSES NICE TO
SEE YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH-
THERE YOU GO SHE'S BEHIND THE
MONITOR I PROMISE YOU SHE'S
THERE AND WE ARE SO LUCKY THAT
AS SHE IS WITH THE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE MISS
FARGAS WE WELCOME YOU IN SO
HAPPY THAT YOU ARE ON BOARD
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO TAKE A
QUICK LOOK FORWARD FOR THE
COMMITTEES CALENDARS- COMPARED
TO LAST YEAR THIS COMMITTEE
WILL BE SEEN A LITTLE LIGHTER-
LIGHTER THE LOAD COMING OVER
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WE EXPECT TO
SEE BETWEEN FIFTY AND SIXTY
FIVE TOTAL BILLS THAT WILL BE
HITTING OUR DESK. THAT BETWEEN
NOW AND JULY EIGHTH THIS
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING
WEEKLY STARTING TODAY THROUGH
JULY EIGHTH EVERY THURSDAY SO
FIFTY SIXTY FIVE BILLS THAT
WILL BE IN FRONT OF US AND WE
WILL BE MEETING EVERY THURSDAY
BETWEEN NOW AND JULY EIGHTH
PLACE IN GENERAL COMMITTEE I
NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A QUICK DISCUSSION ON ALL
ISSUES OF OUR CODE RESPONSE
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE IN
RESPONSE TO THE COPA NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
TODAY THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS THE
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC I CONTINUE
TO HAVE ACCESS WHICH WE WELCOME
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THAT
WE WILL BE TAKING TESTIMONY
TODAY HEARING COMMITTEE AS WELL
AS OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE WE
WELCOME YOUR PARTICIPATION HERE
ARE OUR CONFERENCE LINE TOLL
FREE NUMBERS TODAY IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
HEARING PLEASE DIAL. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. EIGHT SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO THE
NUMBER IN THE CO IS. YOUR WRIST
NOW MAKE SURE YOU TYPE THAT
CODE IN AT ONCE OUR EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR PICKS UP. BUT WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT THAT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN
ZERO. FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. WE WOULD LIKE
EVERYONE TO KNOW THAT TO BE
ABLE TO AVOID ANY COULD SIX
FEET BACK TO PLEASE MUTE. YOUR
DEVICE THAT YOU ARE WATCHING IN
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IN
THE UNLIKELY EVENT AN
INDIVIDUAL BECOMES UNRULY- ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM- DURING THIS. BY
LEGISLATIVE HEARING. BUT AGAIN
THAT'S THE UNLIKELY EVENT. TO
LAYS IN GERMAN THAT WE HAVE
MOVED ON OUR CONSENT CALENDARS.
BUT WE HAVE A QUORUM WE'RE NOT
GOING MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE. OUR LOAN ITEM FOR ACTION
TO DATE THAT'S AB TWO SEVENTY
ONE SUMMARY THIS. DOES
FANTASTIC JOB ON BEHALF IS
DISTRICT WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE
IN FRONT COMMITTEE TODAY. THAT
MR REDUCE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PRESENT WE WELCOME YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
SENATORS SO IT'S GREAT TO SEE
EVERYBODY LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF- FOR THE- THE
CONSIDERATION ENGAGEMENT ON THE
SUPPORT OF OUR DISTRICT AND
REGION- AND THIS LEGISLATION.
WOULD AUTHORIZE- THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT-
VALLEY WATER TO USE A BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT SYSTEM. AND
SELECTING A CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTOR FOR A MAJOR SEISMIC
RETROFIT- A PROJECT ANDERSON
DOWN TO SILICON VALLEY'S
LARGEST AND MOST CRITICAL LOCAL
WATER STRAGE. PROJECT- THE
MOVE. A FACILITY- SHE- WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR WERE
GONNA AT THE DOES. BY SUPPORT
MISS THIS MYSTERY RATING YOU A
THIRTY SECOND TO IF YOU MIND IS
PROVIDE TO TRUNCATED. OF
SUMMARY BILL AND WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FOR MY CENTER SOUTH WELL
I REALLY. THE MOTION AND- AND-
THE SECOND AND SO I THINK WITH
THAT I THINK IT'S BEST TO TURN
IT OVER TO OUR- ONLY WITNESS
WHICH IS THE DEPUTY OPERATING
OFFICER VALLEY WATER CHRIS
TAKES. THANK YOU SO MUCH- WE
ARE GOING TO SAY GOOD MORNING
TO OUR- MODERATOR TODAY WE
HAVE. CHRIS TAKES ON THE LINE
HE'S ATTEMPT DEPUTY. OPERATING
OFFICER. AT CHRIS WE DO HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ENJOYED IN
COMMITTEE HERE TODAY ON. AB TWO
SEVENTY ONE. SO WE'RE GOING TO
ASK FOR A TRUNCATED VERSION OF
YOUR TESTIMONY. CHRIS WELCOME
TO COMMITTEE YOUR NOW LIVE. MY
NAME IS CHRIS HEY OF SERVICE
THE DEPUTY OPERATING OFFICER
FOR DAM SAFETY PICKUP BOOKLET
THERE WITHOUT WATER. I THINK
THE BANK IS A MEMBER THIS
OFFERING AB TWO SEVEN. DOLLAR
HAS A FLEXIBLE TO USE OUT
MARKET PROCUREMENT. THE BILL
DISTRICT PROJECT INSTALLED THEY
COULD BE COMMUNITY WATERS FOR
THE TWO MILLION. I RIGHTS. I
LAYS INJURED COMMITTEE. WE MAY
HAVE A SAID MR HEADACHES GOING
TO ADD. OUR MODERN. MODERATOR I
DID WE LOSE MISTER TAKES OFF
THE LINE. BUT PEOPLE LIKE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU I
BELIEVE I'M STILL HERE THERE IS
NO MISTER HAYES IS BACK MISTER
X. WE WELCOME YOU BACK TO
COMMITTEE. WHAT YOU START AND
WE HEARD- THE LAST WORDS HE
HEARD WAS TWO MILLION FOLKS
THAT- YOU SERVE IN A NIGHT IF
YOU WANT TO PROCEED FROM THERE
SIR MISTER HAKES. WATERSPORT
COMMITTEE THAT OCCUR COUNTY AND
ALL WATER- URGES DR ON A PIECE
OF THE- FIFTY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR- WITH SYSTEM WERE
GREAT THAT YOU'RE WITH US. SO
LAYS IN GERMAN BUT WE LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO DO NOW IS TO BE ABLE
TO CHECK IN. ON ALL ISSUES OF
SUPPORT AS WELL AS OPPOSITION
WE'RE GONNA START RIGHT HERE-
IN THE CHAMBERS TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVENTY ONE. HEARING SEEN
WIND NOW AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM TO
BETTER SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
THAT THAT COULD BE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT KAREN SCENE NO ONE
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE GOING. TO
OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE LINE
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO CHECKED ME TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF. AB TWO SEVENTY ONE
NOW. THANK YOU. MISTER IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO.SOME FOR A BI TO
SELL. ONE THREE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE AND
THEN PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE
QUEUE. INITIAL SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWO SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ALL RIGHT WE
DO HAVE A PARTICIPANT QUEUING
UP ONE MOMENT SURE THING AS
INDIVIDUALS ARE COMING UP WE
WANT TO REMIND FOLKS IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
HEARING THE PHONE NUMBER TOLL
FREE IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. THE
CODE TO BETTER PARTICIPATE IS
EIGHT ONE EIGHT. TWO EIGHT ONE
SEVEN. ALL RIGHT MISTER
MODERATOR. LET'S HEAR FROM OUR
FIRST WITNESS IN SUPPORT. HE WE
WILL GO TO LINE THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HEY GOOD MORNING THIS
IS TYLER MUNCHING ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES AND
TRANSPORT THANK YOU MUCH THANKS
SO MUCH FOR CALLING IN TODAY
TYLER WE'RE GRATEFUL. THAT IT'S
GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER MISTER
MODERATOR. AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO- EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
A BI TWO SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT
MISS MODERATE WILL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU TO CHECK IN ON
ALL ISSUES OF OPPOSITION WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO THOSE
WHO. WISH TO SPEAK IN OR
OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE HAVE
THREE DIFFERENT STEPS TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
WE'RE GONNA START HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS AT WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBER STANDING.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION WE'RE
pROOM NO LOVE- IN OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM SO WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING BACK TO OUR MODERATOR AND
CHECK OUR TOLL FREE
TELECONFERENCE NINE MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS IN
OPPOSITION WE'RE LOOKING FOR
OPPOSITION. OF AB TWO SEVENTY
ONE NOW. TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR A B. TWO
SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR A B. TWO SEVENTY
ONE. ONE MOMENT YOU'RE SURE WE
DO HAVE ONE QUEUING UP. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. SIX AN UPPER BODY
OFF PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SHOW OPPOSITION AN OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOUR LIGHT NUMBER.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND RICHARD MARX AND
ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN THE PLUMBING
HEATING COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA NEITHER ORGANIZATION
OPPOSES BEST VALUE BUT THEY DO
OBJECT TO THE PROVISIONS IN AB
TWO SEVENTY ONE- THAT- TREAT
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENTS. SENATE DISTRICT
MANNER IF THERE IS A PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT IMPOSED ON THE
PROJECT FURTHERMORE WE HAVE
SUGGESTED THAT THE COMMITTEE
ADOPT AMENDMENTS SIMILAR TO THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S IN S. BEFORE
WHEN NINE THAT CREATES A- GOOD
FACE. EXEMPTION FROM THE
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
PROVISIONS SO THE CONTRACTORS
WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO MEET.
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS HAVE AN
OPTION IN THE PROJECT CAN
PROCEED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MARTIN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR CALLING IN WE ALLOWED THIS
REMARKS AND TO BE ABLE TO GO
PASS OUR TYPICAL JUST BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T HAVE A KEY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION MISTER MARKS AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
IN TODAY AND FOR PROVIDING A
PERSPECTIVE REALLY GRATEFUL
SIR. MISTER MODERATOR AND LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
OPPOSITION AB TWO SEVENTY ONE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR A B. TWO SEVENTY
ONE. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY ELSE
IS DOING UP AT THIS TIME. THE
MODERATOR IT'S CAN BE QUICK
MEETING TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
HOPE YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND ARE GOING TO BE
BRINGING IT BACK TO. COMMITTEE
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY. SENATOR DORADO WE'D
LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE HEARINGS SEEN
NINE AS SIMILAR RIVAS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE- WHAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU KNOW
AGAIN- THE CONSIDERATION. FOR
THIS LEGISLATION AND YOU JUST
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE TO
RESPECT US WHEN I VOTE YOUR
PLEASURE WORKLESS SIR THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK
AT THAT'S CALL THE ROLL MISTER
NOW. MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE- A
SENATOR NIELSEN ALL RIGHT
NIELSEN. SENATOR DORADO DORADO
HIS SENATOR HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HIS SENATOR WIENER WIENER HI
FIVE ZERO VOTE PLACE GENUINE
BIPARTISAN FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS THAT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE THANK YOU SO MUCH COULD
YOU SEE THREE TO SIX TRAVELS
HOME THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE. WE'RE GOING TO ADD
THE- MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG
ON TO OUR CONSENT CALENDAR- IT
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO
VOTE MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATOR
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI THAT
SAID I VOTE BY THE MAJORITY
LEADER FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO VOTE
FOR THOSE ELEVEN ITEMS ON OUR
CONSENT COUNTER THE CONCEIT
CONTENT CALENDAR HAS NOW BEEN
COMPLETED AND IS OUT AND WE'RE
GONNA CLOSE THE ROLE. ALRIGHT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE WILL
SEE YOU BACK HERE NEXT THURSDAY
FOR ANOTHER GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE MEETING THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND TO I MISS
MARKETS WELCOME AGAIN MR CANAL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MEETINGS
ADJOURN.